If crowds of women
They wore the uniform of the servants
Jacobin
Step down or leave
I will write it in a better color
Champ de Mars
He was the brother of Mary Antonette
All they do
Treaty of Pellentz
We must have a republican system
We stopped with the previous video at the end of 1789
When the Bastille prison was broken into in Jolay when the people of Paris wanted it
To take the weapons that the Bastille contained
To free some political prisoners with the aim of
To protect themselves from the tyrannical ruler Louis XVI
Louis XVI was forced to
He says: Well, the National Assembly, I will not
Stand in your way after the day
Because he absorbed whenever he tried to
Stop their work, this leads to more
Of the tension in the political situation
So in late 1789 chaos broke out in many
Cities of France
So the National Association contributed to the composition
Constitution will be applied and applied in 1791
But they began to make plans
To form this constitution
But in the month of August 1789 they showed their version
Of the Declaration of Freedom
Declaration of human rights and citizens
If things were good at that time they would wait
For a few years to write the constitution and perhaps
That constitution was a royal constitution
But of particular misfortune to Louis XVI
Things were not satisfactory
As I mentioned this thing began
Because the people were starving
We have this financial crisis for our famine
In October 1789 - we were still in that year - October 1789
Some rumors spread that Mary Antonyt
The king's wife was hiding bags of wheat in Versailles
So the people began to imagine bags of wheat
In Versailles and at a time when people could not even find
the bread
Bread was the staple food
So crowds of peasants marched
To Versailles
Be armed
This is a picture of the crowds of peasant women who went
To Versailles
They went to Farassy and in fact they managed
To break into the palace
And they demanded - because they doubted what he was doing
Louis XVI and his wife Marie Antoinette in Versailles
They demanded that they move to Paris
If crowds of women
They got their demands
This led to the transfer of Louis XVI and his wife Marie Antonet
to Paris . Because they can not
There is hiding wheat
They will be surrounded by all
These unkind people who are watching
All they do
I think the most important factor is that the people were hungry
Rumors spread that the king was storing wheat
But another rumor began to spread that the king was
Disrespectful with the symbols of new France
With the National Assembly
This also made the people angry
In fact all learned
Including Louis XVI he did not like what was happening
Did not like the idea of ​​the Royal Constitution
Which was formed and the amount of power and power that he would have lost
To the National Assembly
So we have this uncomfortable situation
At the beginning of 1790 he was king and king
As if they were being held in a house called the Tuileries Palace
And you have the National Assembly established
the Constitution
They have the task of establishing the constitution
They all took the tennis court section
At the same time you have all over France
Riot control
This is France
In all the countries there were rioters
Some people did not live up to their French Revolution
And they were losing
All the people were conspiring against each other
And you have some nobles who said:
do you know ?
I do not like the evolution of it
We have a lot of violence
The people are angry
I will take my money and all I can pack
I will deceive the country
I will leave the country
And you have a class of nobles leaving France
They were called immigrants
I know I did not utter it correctly
They had the idea that he was living well here
In France, why not live well
I'd better leave. This idea began to occur in 1791
If in 1790 it was an uncomfortable period
In 1791 this idea was attempted
Getting away from the danger King Louis XVI began to wonder
And Mary Antonette
But could not leave the country
They did not trust Great Britain
They did not trust these nearby children to blow them
political asylum
One of the generals who sympathized with him
They told them the least they would do was go to the border
In order to escape from all these problems
That occur
So wear the clothes of the servants - and this informs you
Their personalities -
They wore the uniform of the servants
They made the servants dressed in noble costumes
So they make them servants to set them ambush
After all they were trying to escape from Bryce
Dressed as servants the king and the king - the king tried
To escape to the ownership of this general
But when they arrived in Varen here
You know them
They arrested them and took them prisoner
And brought them back to Paris
They launched the event
Escape to Paris or Escape from Paris
Any name you like
In advance Louis XVI began
I am impressed by what happened
So they tried to flee
But the people returned them
Perhaps I began to imagine that a lot of people
Do not like the king
They did not like the idea of ​​having a king
And more revolutionary and extremist group
They were called Jacobin
After the royal family attempted to evade and be returned
They said it would be better
Is there a king at all?
For you, the National Assembly, you shall give
Any power in the constitution
For the king?
We must have a republican system
This in short means - there are a lot of definitions
For the term republican but easier
It is a state without a king without
The emperor without his king
So they said we do not need you National Assembly
You are trying to solve the problem
But we do not match our thoughts
We want to lack the existence of the royal government
all of which
And the fact that Louis VI tried to escape
We see that here he stepped down from the throne
Step down or leave
They began organizing themselves in Paris
Here at the Champ de Mars
I know that you are wrong
This is his current picture
They began to collect votes
In this public park they carry out an idea
We do not need a king
We want to be a republican system
The National Assembly does not solve the problem
So the General Assembly gathered here
Things became out of control in the Champ de Mars
So they sent soldiers
To calm the situation
These forces were previously controlled
National Association
The people who controlled the situation
For their possession of the third power
But the situation has increased
They threw stones at the soldiers
Some of the soldiers at the beginning did
Shooting in the air
But in the end it led things out of control
They were fired on the crowds
Killing 50 people
And this is the carrot
Or the massacre of Champ de Mars
I know that you are wrong
This is not a video in teaching French pronunciation
This led to the anger of the people more
People are still starving
The problem did not resolve
The king and the king were hated
All expected them to try to return
For the throne and power
Try to escape
Jacobin or the year
The thorans who were their Jacobin commanders
When they began to propose the formation of a republican system
And that there is no family owner
They gathered people here
Which was under the leadership of the National Assembly
They fired at the crowds and killed civilians
Because they threw stones
They were probably large stones
But you can imagine this will make people hungry
The press is more angry
And in order to make the people more mad with doubt that the king
And the king is trying to return to power you also had
Two forces are suddenly trying to engage themselves
French Revolution
Let's mention it on the Han side
Because this information is when you learn it
In European history it will be a bit difficult to understand
You have these states that are so true
You have Austria .., you shaded it in orange
This map is a map of the present
But in the orange show you how Austria was
In another time
In 1789, 1790, 1791
This is in Russia
I want to show you that this is very different from
Austria at present
This is Austria today
Russia does not exist in the present world
And I have the name of the Roman empretorism
A union with these other kingdoms or empires
Where was her name?
I want to mention a quick information on the side
The Roman Empire was sacred as Voltaire said
Neither sacred nor Roman nor empire
He was right
The definition of the monarch was unclear to the German
And its sectors - particularly the German Kingdom
If you notice, she now has what is known in Germany
And the most powerful authorities in the Roman Empire
Or strengthened two powers in the Roman Empire
It was Austria
The governor of Austria had a title
Emperor of the Holy Roman Empire
He is Leopold II
If Leopold II was the emperor of the Roman Empire of the Holy
But he was not the founder of the Roman Empire
The founder of the Roman Apostolic Empire was of Rome
He observed that nothing in the Roman Empire was sacred at that time
Simplifies anything in Rome
So we said Roman were not because they did not
They speak ethnic
We speak of German-speaking people
It was not an empire
It was not a government with a fixed organization
It was an unorganized union of some countries
But the most influential sense
Were under the authority of Austria or
Leopold
The ruler was not only or had him
The abbreviation for that country is abbreviated
He ruled Austria or could say imperialism in
that time
He was the brother of Mary Antonette
Leopold II was her brother
Leopold II and the governor of Prussia, Frank William
It is a strong nation
I will write it in a better color
They issued the Treaty of Pellentz
I will write it
This added more anger and humiliation to
People of France
Treaty of Pellentz
And took place in August. and I want to
Explain this
In the month of John 1791 tried war
They were arrested in Varen
In Julai 1791 you have the massacre of Champ de Mars
This made the people very wary of the government
The idea is they do not want them to increase
And the people became more angry
And now you have the Treaty of Piltons
Of these Western countries and one of them is governed by them
Brother of the royal family
This treaty is mainly provided for
The restoration of power to power in France
They did not want to
Intervene militarily
But a declaration that they do not agree with what is happening
in France
And they were not so serious about it
But the people of France took it seriously
Very serious
You have these troops on the border here
And you have Austria and Prussia
This was not something people could do
To insult him
This increased their fear that the royal family would try
Planning to return to strength
And you'll be surprised
This increased the anger of Jacobin
They wanted to be Republican
So I'll stop here in this video
You can see things at the beginning of this video were bad
And now it is worsening
in France
The people are now wondering whether they need it
King or king
Western forces began to intervene
And saying that she does not like what happened with the king and the king
They have removed power
Maybe that will hurt them and their people get these ideas
And so is her brother so
I will help you
This increased the fear of the people
The National Assembly was at the beginning of the revolution
They are now
The massacres are inhabited by people
This will lead to an ugly and bad period
In French history
And you will notice that this will lead to his era
Which is called the era of terrorism
We'll see it in the next video